[Music]
this doesn't make sense
where do we start at the very beginning
[Music]
i got in the elevator with these two
weirdos then tim
got in the elevator
approximately 12 minutes from now i will
be murdered
tim cono's death has been ruled a
homicide
and apparently one of you jerk-offs did
it
i can't stop thinking about them neither
can i we should do our own true crime
podcast
we're gonna go down there and look
around for clues you want to come
do i want to break into a dead guy's
apartment and go through all his [ __ ]
sounds like an afternoon
[Music]
right now the only thing that matters is
that there's a killer on the loose in
our building
oh that is a very good line badly
delivered but a good line
i think we're onto something big here
and these are candid photos i took of
our neighbors
why are they all selfies so i don't draw
suspicion
so hot in here do we have to do this in
a closet the acoustics are better and
trust me you need acoustics i'm gonna
pass out
get the who the how the why and the wine
get the what or the what
see why would you say what i never said
what there's no what
[ __ ] just got super real i think our
list of suspects just got longer
hold on
get out of the building now exclamation
point exclamation point
oh my god
[Music]
keep your eyes peeled anything can be a
clue
[Music]
there's a very strong chance the killer
is musical superstar sting
the guy from you too
[Music]
do you consent to being recorded just
say anything to agree no
please thanks perfect
um i like the emotion keep that i kind
of need you to enunciate better
do you have anything the crying is
covering the dialogue oh that's a good
that's a good name okay
when you're ready and actually
[Music]
you